[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo und willkommen zu einem Cold Case
bei Tatort Deutschland ich bin Mirko
Kasimir und ich bin Stefan Netzeband und
zum Glück das ist der Witz ist der Code
Case seit ein paar Wochen keiner mehr
wir besprechen heute einen Fall der erst
kürzlich gelöst werden konnte viele
Jahre nachdem was passiert ist er
beginnt im Hochsommer 1992 in
Nordrhein-Westfalen wir sind in
Meerbusch das ist eine mittelgroße Stadt
im Rhein-Kreis Neuss und liegt zwischen
Düsseldorf und Krefeld das ging typisch
nordrhein-westfälisch aber es gibt zwei
Besonderheiten mehr Busch ist sehr
ländlich es gibt viele Wälder Wiesen und
Äcker entlang des Rheins und im
Vergleich zu anderen Städten sind die
Einwohner wohlhabend am Morgen des 21
August 1992
findet ein Spaziergänger mit zwei
Schäferhunden die halbnackte Leiche
einer Frau sie liegt in einem meistfeld
in dem die Pflanzen jetzt gerade ein
Meter 70 hochstehen der Fund sorgt für
einen Großeinsatz am Rande des Feldes
stehen schon bald die Fahrzeuge von
Polizei und Spurensicherung sowie ein
Leichenwagen erstmal ist unklar um wen
es sich bei der Toten handelt aber in
ihrer Jeans findet die Kripo mehrere
hundert Mark Muscheln und die
Visitenkarte eines französischen Hotels
in der Bretagne schnell steht fest dass
Opfer wurde nur 5 m vom Fundort entfernt
durch vier Messerstiche in die Brust
getötet wenig später hat die tote auch
einen Namen sie kriegt sie zu diesem
Zeitpunkt 50 Jahre alt sie war zwar in
Düsseldorf geboren lebt damals aber mit
ihrem Lebensgefährten in Süddeutschland
Sigrid C wird 1942 geboren sie besucht
die Höhere Handelsschule und arbeitet
danach Düsseldorf in einer
Marketing-Agentur Ende der 60er Jahre
wandert sie mit ihrem damaligen Ehemann
nach Kanada aus aber weder das
auswandererleben noch die Ehe halten
lang schon bald trennt sich Sigrid von
ihrem Mann und kehrt nach Deutschland
zurück in den 80er Jahren lernt sie
ihren letzten Lebensgefährten kennen mit
dem sie nach Freiburg zieht sie arbeitet
als Fremdenführerin Freunde und Bekannte
schildern Sigrid als zurückhaltend aber
durchaus selbstbewusst auf einem ihrer
letzten Fotos sieht man eine schlanke
Frau mit langen hellen Haaren einer
prägnanten etwas eckigen Nase und einer
sehr großen weißen Brille zwei drei Mal
im Jahr kommt sie in die alte Heimat in
NRW zurück um ihren Bruder zu besuchen
so auch jetzt in August 1992 am Tag
bevor Siegfried tot aufgefunden wird
trifft sich Freunde von früher später am
Nachmittag geht sie zum Zahnarzt
gegen 18:30 Uhr verlässt sie die Praxis
danach will Sigrid offenbar spazieren
gehen Zeugen sehen Sie am Abend zwischen
19:45
Uhr in der Feldmark auf einer Bank
zusammen mit einem Mann zusammen mit
ihrem Mörder die Polizei tut auf jeden
Fall alles um den Fall schnell zu lösen
Zeugen werden befragt alle verfügbaren
Spuren am Fundort im Maisfeld gesichert
die Obduktion bestätigt dass Sigrid C an
den vier Messerstichen starb genauer
gesagt verblutete sie die Ermittler
vermuten recht schnell dass es sich bei
dem Mann auf der Bank um ihren späteren
Mörder gehandelt haben könnte offenbar
überwältigt er sie am Rande des Feldes
sieht sie dort hinein und tötet sie und
zwar indem er sie erst wirkt und dann
auf sie einsticht Siegrid wehrt sich
unter ihren Fingernägeln wird fremdes
Gewebe gefunden und gesichert zu einer
Vergewaltigung kommt es nicht mit Hilfe
von zeugenbeschreibungen lässt die
Mordkommission das Phantombild eines
blonden Mannes des mutmaßlichen Mörders
erstellen und verteilt Fahndungsplakate
und tatsächlich wird der blonde Mann
gefunden aber für den eigentlichen
Todeszeitpunkt später am Abend hatte ein
Alibi in der Öffentlichkeit heißt der
Fall längst Mord im Maisfeld es wird
solide Polizeiarbeit geleistet aber
leider ergebnislos der Tod von Sigrid C
wird zum Cold Case drei Umstände seien
hier aber erwähnt die noch wichtig
werden
erstens die Beweise die die Ermittler
und Gerichtsmediziner gesammelt und
gesichert haben werden
selbstverständlich aufgehoben zweitens
holt die Polizei ungelöste Fälle aus den
Aktenschränken und prüft sie erneut und
drittens macht die medizinische Forensik
gerade in diesen Jahren schnelle und
große Fortschritte es ist die
Untersuchung von Erbgut die die
Polizeiarbeit von Grund auf verbessert
bildchef Reporter Frank Schneider hat
schon viele Fälle erlebt in denen die
DNA den Durchbruch brachte man glaubt
ihr heute DNA gab es immer schon man
kann sich ja gar nicht mehr vorstellen
eine Mord Ermittlung ohne DNA DNA ist ja
gefühlt so dass Allheilmittel dazu muss
man aber sagen DNA ist und bleibt es
heute ein Indiz kein Beweis es muss noch
einen zusätzlichen Beweis geben es
reicht nicht aus nur die DNA zu haben
von einem Täter man muss auch erklären
wie die da hinkommen man muss in den
Motiv haben man muss andere Dinge haben
die man den Täter nachweisen kann alle
glauben immer nur die DNA erreicht das
ist aber so nicht dazu muss man sagen es
hat 1984 begonnen in England da gab es
zwei schreckliche Morde an jungen
Mädchen und da hat man zum ersten Mal
versucht diese DNA zu extrahieren hat
das auch in Teilen geschafft und hat
damals feststellen können ja wir haben
hier ist mit einem Serientäter zu tun
eine derselbe hat beide Mädchen getötet
man muss sich aber vorstellen damals war
zum Beispiel eine Blutspur ein ungefähr
1 € Stück große Blutspur notwendig um
überhaupt eine dnh zu erheben heute
reichen Teile einer Hautschuppe ähm das
sind Unterschiede und Fortschritte die
da einfach die Laboruntersuchungen
gemacht haben und die Wissenschaft
gemacht haben die sind gigantisch und
ermöglichen dadurch so viel und wenn man
natürlich konkreten Fall zurückkommen
aus dem Maisfeld das ist ja gerade das
Spannende damals wurde zum Glück alles
schon aufbewahrt ähm dieser Fall liegt
eben auch so zurück da wusste man schon
mit der DNA werden mir große
Fortschritte machen und dann wurden eben
Spuren vernünftig asaviert heißt
gesichert luftdicht verpackt und da
wurden eben auch immer den Opfern die
Fingernägel abgeschnitten und hier was
auch so die Fingernägel waren noch da
und aus denen konnte man erneut mit den
neuen Methoden doch noch eine DNA
extrahieren oder sind wir wieder bei
diesen Hautschuppen was ich eben
beschrieben habe und das reicht in
diesem konkreten Fall aus nach so langer
Zeit dann doch noch den Täter zu
überführen den häufig kratzen ja Opfer
die die Täter weil sich ja wehren wollen
also vielleicht auch unbewusst es ist
ein abwehrverletzung und die sind dann
unter den Nägeln in der Regel und
deswegen sind die Nägel eine ganz große
Quelle sozusagen von denen arspulen für
die Ermittler Routine mäßig werden bei
ermittlernen ganz Deutschland immer
wieder ungelöste Fälle hervorgeholt und
Spuren mit modernen Analyse Techniken
nachgeprüft beim fallsekret C ist es im
Jahr 2021 soweit das Landeskriminalamt
Nordrhein-Westfalen lässt die
Gewebeproben von Sigrid Fingernagel
erneut kontrollieren
und im März 2022 meldet die Datenbank
einen sogenannten
personenspurtreffer den Alarm nimmt der
erste Kriminalhauptkommissar Guido Adler
entgegen er ist Leiter der zuständigen
Mordkommission Düsseldorf der Treffer
besagt folgendes das Gewebe stammt vom
heute 63 Jahre alten Manfred C der
ursprünglich aus Düsseldorf stammt das
alles kann in den Datenbanken
abgeglichen werden weil der Mann bereits
wegen Mordes im Gefängnis sitzt am 12
August 1995 tötete der gelernte
Automechaniker Manfred C die Schülerin
Marta g in Bad Liebenzell im nördlichen
Schwarzwald
das Mädchen ist damals 12 Jahre alt
sie fügt ihr tiefe Schnitte an Hals
Brust und Genitalbereich zu in einem
ersten Prozess wird Manfred C seinerzeit
vom Landgericht Tübingen wegen
Totschlags verurteilt aber seine
Verteidigung liegt Revision ein und so
gibt der Bundesgerichtshof den
schuldbruch erstmal auf bei der
angeordneten Neuauflage des Prozesses
bekommt Manfred C die Höchststrafe
lebenslange Haft wegen Mordes mit
besonderer Schwere der Schuld wer also
ist Manfred C was hat ihn zum zweifachen
Mörder gemacht laut Mord Ermittler Guido
Adler warzes Kindheit prekär seine
Mutter war Alkoholikerin den Vater
lernte der Junge nie kennen trotzdem
schloss sie eine Ausbildung zum
Mechaniker ab Anfang 1992 lernte er
seine spätere Ehefrau kennen aus
beruflichen Gründen zieht sie aber in
den Schwarzwald in dieser Zeit passieren
zwei weitere Dinge Manfred ermordet in
den Feldern am Rhein bei Meerbusch
Sigrid C und er zieht kurz darauf seiner
Frau hinterher in den Schwarzwald zwei
Jahre darauf zerbricht die Ehe und Zeh
wird auch noch zum Kindermörder nachdem
die DNA-Analysen im Jahr 2022
übereinstimmen wird sicherheitshalber
noch eine Speichelprobe wenn Manfred C
vorgenommen auch sie deckt sich mit den
Spuren aus dem Maisfeld juristisch
folgerichtig stellt die
Staatsanwaltschaft einen Haftbefehl
gegen C aus obwohl der ja schon einsetzt
Maut Ermittler Adler ist sicher dass
beide Morde von Manfred C sexuell
motiviert sind im droht einerseits jetzt
ein neuer Prozess andererseits kann sich
selbst dadurch für ihn nicht viel ändern
denn die in Deutschland mögliche
Höchststrafe hat er ja bereits für den
Mord im Schwarzwald erhalten aber Bild
Reporter Frank Schneider ist es sehr
wichtig dass die Lösung eines
einen hohen Wert hat ja bei den cold
cases ist noch etwas anders immens
wichtig wir dürfen auch nicht die
Angehörigen der Opfer aus dem Blick
verlieren und die haben ihr Leben lang
die Frage warum was ist da passiert und
das ist eigentlich der Mensch ist eh tot
aber das ist das verheerende häufig für
die Menschen noch schlimmer als wenn
jemand gar nicht mehr auftaucht einfach
weg ist und das zermürbt die Menschen
sie können eigentlich mit der wirklichen
Trauerarbeit nie anfangen weil sie
einfach nicht wissen was passiert ist
sie wollen diese Fragen geklärt haben
deswegen sind die Cookies Ermittlung
auch immens wichtig für die Angehörigen
vielleicht mal vorweg natürlich ist es
auch nicht wie in dem Fall so dass die
Täter immer sitzen es gibt auch Täter
die möglicherweise noch gar nicht in der
Scheidung getreten sind das heißt immer
noch frei rumlaufen und deshalb
natürlich auch dann bestraft werden
müssen wenn es so ist wie in dem Fall
dass der Täter bereits wegen einem
anderen Tötungsdelikt so lange schon
sitzt und lebenslang bekommen hat dann
kann es trotzdem wichtig sein weil auch
wenn die besonders Schwere der Schuld
schon festgestellt wurde für den Laien
erklärt das heißt er kann frühestens
noch 25 Jahren den Antrag stellen
freigelassen zu werden kann es aber auch
noch zusätzlich die Sicherungsverfahren
geben und wenn wir uns über das sind
Täter vielleicht bei den Taten erst
Anfang 20 war oder von mir ist auch Ende
20 Anfang 30 und dann vielleicht 25 30
Jahre absitzt kann er vielleicht noch
mal raus und wenn jetzt hier
festgestellt wird Moment wir haben es
hier mit einem sehr intäter zu tun dann
kann er auch die sogenannte
Sicherungsverwahrung bekommen das heißt
ein Gutachter entscheidet dann immer nur
darf der überhaupt jemals noch mal raus
er muss dann ständig begutachtet werden
und das ist natürlich ein Stück weit
auch Schutz der Öffentlichkeit und der
Bevölkerung Frank Schneider wann der
Prozess gegen Manfred C am Landgericht
Düsseldorf beginnt steht noch nicht fest
Manfred sie ließ über seinen
Pflichtverteidiger mitteilen dass er mit
den Mord Ermittlern über den Fall Sigrid
C nicht sprechen wird und damit nähern
wir uns so etwas wie einem Fazit die
DNA-Analyse hat nach 30 Jahren einen
Mordfall gelöst das macht Sigrid nicht
wieder lebendig aber ihr früherer
Lebensgefährte aus Freiburg zeigte sich
gegenüber Kommissar Guido Adler sehr
bewegt über die Gewissheit die es
endlich gibt das spricht auch ein
bisschen für die Argumente von Frank
Schneider finde ich und wer weiß
vielleicht muss am Ende auch Mörder
Manfred C länger im Gefängnis bleiben
wenn es einen neuen Prozess gibt so oder
so geht schon jetzt was Ermittler Adler
zur Lösung des Falls gesagt hat er sagt
das ist in höchstem Maße befriedigend
für die kriminalistische Arbeit einen
Punkt haben wir noch bzw Frank Schneider
möchte noch auf etwas Hinweisen mit
einer Ausweitung der DNA-Untersuchung
könne man sogar noch mehr Fälle lösen
wir haben genau um diese Revolution muss
man es ja wirklich in dieser
revolutionäre Entwicklung einmal klar zu
machen damals braucht man ihre Mengen
und konnte nur eine ganz kryptische DNA
überhaupt feststellen heute ist es so
die Forensiker und Wissenschaftler
könnten heute nicht nur diesen
genetischen Fingerabdruck von dem wir
immer sprechen herstellen sondern
wirklich ein genetischen Steckbrief das
heißt sie würden auswerten die kodierten
Bereiche der DNA das sind eben die wo
die genetischen Merkmale große ins
hinterlegt sind bislang werden nur die
nicht kodierten Bereiche untersucht in
denen keine Erbinformationen vorhanden
sind das ist auch so
datenschutzrechtlich vorgeschrieben es
ist auch bisher nicht geändert worden
und ich frage mich ob wir da nicht
umdenken müssen denn die DNA wird ja nur
dann gesichert und sie wird auch nur
dann eben auf diesen kodierten Bereich
untersucht wenn wir hier von schwersten
Straftaten sprechen sprich von
Tötungsdelikten oder ähnlichem oder
vielleicht Vergewaltigung sehen und ich
glaube dann wäre es immens wichtig alles
auszuschöpfen was die Wissenschaft heute
kann und dann mehr oder weniger aus
einer DNA ein Phantombild zu erstellen
genau zu sagen wie alt ist der welche
Aussehen hat er welche Haarfarbe hatte
man kann natürlich auch Haare färben
aber man hätte schon eine super Aussage
darüber wie der Täter aussieht und das
in Verbindung mit anderen hinweisen da
bin ich felsenfest von überzeugt da
würden bestimmt noch mal 50 60% der
Täter überführt eine Fahndung per DNA
also da wird es bestimmt noch spannende
politische Debatten geben und damit sind
wir am Ende unserer heutigen Ausgabe
angelangt
vielen Dank dass ihr wieder mit dabei
wart euer Mirko und euer Stefan